Hello Freak bitches.
How about Donald Trump going hard at ESPN?
Yeah,
but he's wrong.
He's so we're leaving.
No,
there were ratings are up like that's so crazy.
Ravens aren't up.
Are they down because of him?
People leaving cable and somebody said that the ratings are up though.
Recent ratings.
Maybe.
I just read things and I just go with them.
NFL is back.
I mean they're just up because the summer's over,
but,
but in general they're down just in,
you know,
ESP,
they had all those cuts who had kind a bunch of people budget cuts.
He cut so much talent,
but that was it.
Oh,
what's her name?
Jim.
The hill came out was like on her,
granted she is an employee,
the of ESPN,
but on her personal social media on Twitter,
she was saying he's a race,
stuff like that.
He's a white supremacist and a,
she said he's the worst president of her lifetime and a lot of people said that.
It's just the fact that she's a public media figures.
Everybody wanted her fired and that this is like,
it's weird outrage culture we live in.
Right.
She's entitled to Her fucking opinion.
Now,
the thing is,
does ESPN want people on their network being all political and talking about
shit like that on their social media and do they have rules about that?
Because some companies do have rules about that,
whether you agree with those rules or not.
Some companies do have rules on what you can and can't say on social media,
but here's the thing that I found fascinating.
Donald Trump didn't talk about her,
talked about ESPN.
I thought that was a chicken shit thing to do.
Like there was a woman who works for ESPN.
Hold on.
Oh yes,
that's true.
That's what I'm saying.
There's a woman that works for Espn,
a very specific person,
not ESPN.
You know,
telling lies should apologize or whatever the fuck he wrote.
He didn't call her out.
I think he's,
he seems like he's knows he can't do it,
especially not now.
Everybody thinks you're a white supremacist can pick on the black lady.
He picked on Rosie O'donnell all day long.
Right?
He'll go after everybody else.
Call him a loser girl,
Miss America.
And her little speech slammed him too.
She would like said all bunch of shit about him.
And did you see this Jones?
The host does that Kirk Cameron,
it looks like Kirk Cameron.
That's homeboy from survivor.
Who is it from survivor?
I'm sorry.
Not from thrive.
Some bachelor Bachelorette.
You ever seen him getting roasted and when he's accused of cheating on his girl
classic anyways,
yeah,
that Miss America,
she said Brown shit about Trump and no one's going after her necessarily.
She's quote unquote gaining millions of fans right now.
Right.
But what's interesting is I watched someone posted something about uh,
Anthony Bordain.
Anthony Bordain was caught by TMZ of the airport.
Okay.
Very quick.
Sort of silly interview.
They ask them a question,
if you had to cook for Kim Jong Lewin and Donald Trump,
what would you serve?
And he goes,
hemlock.
And he walks away.
It's a joke.
It's a fucking,
one line is also funny.
He's a funny guy.
He says a one liner and all these people are saying,
should he be fired from CNN for saying that he would poison Trump if he had who
you know,
good luck to secret service is going to contact you.
And so I look at his fucking Twitter page man and it's crazy.
All these fucking psychos are telling the secret service.
They should investigate it.
CNN or are you going to fire him like you fired razor as long with people,
man,
outrage out.
Excuse me,
outrage culture.
People are getting excited about things being outrageous instead of just going
the fuck this weed is got me coffin instead of just looking at it and going,
well I don't agree with that.
Fuck that guy.
Or going well that was obviously a joke,
which was like the normal person would do it.
Like affects you like not at all.
Do you really think that Anthony Bordain wants to fucking poison Donald Trump
and they should lose your jobs?
Exactly.
Well hills,
she's amazing by the way she's raised on his culture.
Outrage culture.
People just decide they can try to affect something and then things start
getting ramped up.
The momentum kicks in.
All these other people jump on board and they get excited about being a part of
a group that wants to get Anthony Bordain kicked off these yesterday,
what they want,
some sort of weird direction.
They think they're important enough where they can get these people fire and
they think if they get together enough,
they're going to have the power to affect that person's life.
Even believe they're right.
Bunch of pitches.
Right.
And I kept seeing,
you know,
threatening the life of Potus.
I kept saying,
you've got it.
What are you talking about?
The king,
you guys are out of your mind.
This is a person with a terrible job.
[inaudible] game of Thrones.
Donald Trump is a person with a job that no one wants.
Okay.
That's what he is doing a good job at it.
No,
but is anybody doing a good job at it?
No.
Okay.